heavy smog hangs over the wide Boulevard
leading to new delhi's indiaia gate a
day after Diwali celebrations it seems
the Festival of Lights has been replaced
by Gloom pollution levels dropped at the
end of last week after heavy rains but
requests that residents scale back their
celebrations seem to have been
ignored pollution was expected to
increase people set of firecrackers it
happens every
year people set of Fire crackers despite
the government asking them not to do so
I saw them near my house and I couldn't
sleep although the celebrations in the
capital were more muted this year
fireworks were seen and heard throughout
the night across India hundreds of
millions of people celebrated by
lighting candles marking the symbolic
victory of light over Darkness but those
tasked with reducing the pollution
levels I think the government needs to
take a broader approach in order to
focus on Delhi I think really does take
away from the fact that this is a
regional issue um if you go and measure
the air quality anywhere in Punjab right
now or even all the way down um East in
Bihar you'll probably be see seeing
similar levels of air pollution if not
higher in some cases with the Diwali
festivities over now the cleanup begins
sweeping the streets may only take a day
clearing the air pollution is likely to
take much longer Tony Chang Al
jaero